evolved is an asymmetrical cooperative
competitive multiplayer action shooter
for for the one coming to Xbox one
februari 10th set on the savage planet
of shear of all plays out as a series of
epic boss battles or the boss is a
player controlled monster today we would
like to share with you the new map the
distillery with dynamic snowstorms large
altitude changes and secret waterfall
rounds this compact battleground is full
of options for both hunters and monsters
alike let's jump in a match already in
progress to show you how a new map and
mixing the hunters changes the game for
both sides DB Sinclair and J party here
jumping right into the action in our new
map distillery alright folks we are
looking at a game well underway here we
are following a stage to Kraken as he
gets the final tasty meets he needs to
get to this final level stage 3 and boy
does he need a DP Sinclair that health
bar at the top of your screen looking
real low very low health J party that
full armor allows him to get away here
are the hunters focusing on some local
wildlife this map no different from the
others we've shown before the local
wildlife could take you out just as
easily as a monster yeah so important to
be delicate around this environment here
you never know when you'll get caught
out and there we go this monster getting
that evolved he's going to make it to
stage three in that cocoon now selecting
his final abilities this is so important
for him to select good abilities the
final encounter will be happening soon
and here come the hunters led by Hank on
support you're seeing a lot of the
verticality of this map here also to
note here on the distillery snow storms
will occasionally come in that can wreak
havoc for hunters and monsters alike
yeah the hunters catch you after the
monster here we'll see if they get that
trap at the mobile arena and there it
goes down here this will be the final
stand for one of the squads here we go J
party doing big damage as the monster
and as you can see here ladies and
gentlemen we are mixing and matching
hunters in the game of evolved you
always need a salt you always need
trapper medic and support but within
that you're able to mix and match
characters like you're seeing here we've
got Hank and support Griffin on trapper
and here comes Lazarus with the Lazarus
of
ice as the medic yeah getting that
clutch revive here that's so important
for the team to work together use those
abilities here we see our support class
ank with that shield weapon this is so
important as long as that is on an
allied they will be invulnerable keeps
your teammates up and in the front lines
he can't shield everybody though J party
and here's lazard's no shield on him
Lazarus goes down it's down to support
and assault a big orbital barrage coming
in doing some damage there look at the
monster J party down to half a bar of
hell oh this so little help left he's
just out of steam here these hunters
have to pull this victory out here
assault goes down we're down to Hank
Hank could do this with the laser cutter
here comes the monster look see oh no he
gets the leap attack
you
you